following president biden's catastrophic
withdrawal and the taliban's victory in
afghanistan america may be facing an
elevated terror threat here at home from
groups like al qaeda remember al qaeda
in just 25 days we will be commemorating
the 20th anniversary of the horrible 9
11 attacks that took so many american
lives and now top pentagon officials and
others are warning that terrorists
backed in or rather based in taliban
controlled afghanistan could launch new
attacks here on the u.s homeland now
given that nightmare scenario republican
lawmakers now slamming president biden
and accusing him of putting american
lives at risk
the biggest thing sean it's a disaster
for our counterterrorism america is less
safe
al qaeda 3.0
will come roaring back al qaeda and the
taliban are absolutely married at the
hip but this time when we go back in
the taliban are going to be better armed
with taxpayer-funded equipment we have
no bases in the region and we have no
local allies because they've all been
hunted down i want to see resignations i
want to see resignations also greg but i
have a slightly different take on it
remember what happened the last time the
taliban hosted al qaeda al qaeda hid us
so we came back we wiped out the taliban
we took their country right in other
words their support of al qaeda cost
them their country for 20 years
why would they be so eager now that they
have their country back to sponsor they
are sorry well i mean it's also there
might be there is a silver lining once
isis seized land they had to keep it and
once you start keeping land you become a
target you can't be underground forever
so if the taliban starts doing some
really really heinous crap we can
they're going to have to be public about
it and if al qaeda comes out we have to
create a way we i call you know the pest
control analogy terror control but i am
happy that
admiral uh millie is that his name he
moved up the terror threat it is now uh
more dangerous than a white republican
but still not as lethal as a trump voter
you gotta remember the war on terror was
supposed to shift to white supremacy so
this has got to chafe don lemon's butt
because they're not good cnn's not going
to be able to pull this anymore because
now you got to deal with the taliban i'm
just hoping that if if if if the terror
if the taliban creates a government
it is easier to annihilate them if we
choose because they're now not hiding in
tunnels as long as they don't bring
white supremacists yes exactly they
could be white supremacists
but dana you disagree with my analysis
that why support al-qaeda i think when
al-qaeda is so hot
well i don't disagree that that would
make logical sense
the problem is al qaeda has already
pledged to be there and the taliban has
been working with them and the u.n
report just recently said that so i
think that's the facts on the ground
already are that it's not just al qaeda
but every other sort of radical islamic
terrorism group
now even if they don't come to
afghanistan that might be where the
taliban gets smart right maybe they say
well don't come here they don't get a
hug
do they really they're like 20 of them
right 20 different there are fractions
right now i think though
um
i think the most important thing in the
last 20 years has been that we didn't
start the war
remember the war came to us and then we
decided to go on the offense and that
has to remain so in if this helps
remind everybody that you can't get into
september 10th thinking
and complacency then that won't be a bad
thing remember the 3 a.m phone call ad
of 2016.
we didn't talk too much about that in
2020 but we probably should have
so what do you think about al qaeda
well and the legitimacy of this group
that was basically defunct coming back
to life because of the taliban well i
think the immediate threat now are the
americans that are still in afghanistan
and if one of those americans or one of
our allies dies at the hands of the
taliban joe thinks things bad or bad now
after that happens it's going to be like
an iran hostage situation
also these refugees some of them deserve
to have amnesty and to come here do i
trust joe biden to vet them of course i
don't it does not look like
good vetting is going on at the kabul
airport right now don't you and to think
that the guy who let the boston bombers
come in here after russia said hey watch
out for this children
they were alerted by moscow to this
administration and we didn't do anything
because there was this misspelling they
also let the san bernardino shooter in
here after his social media was he was
last year his wife plastered with
jihadist propaganda geraldo i don't
trust joe devette he's incompetent so
that's a threat to the homeland too
great question today at the briefing to
jake sullivan woman don't know her name
had a mask on she said what about the
nato allies what about taiwan what about
south korea are we going to defend them
after what we just witnessed and a
propaganda
gift to russia
china north korea they're just going to
tell those targets you think the
americans are competent enough to save
your butt it's going to hurt there's a
big difference between taiwan and south
korea and afghanistan and afghanistan's
in the middle of nowhere you do you what
was your first feeling when you saw the
crowds at the airport uh yesterday and
sunday just that it was it was a
horrible visual that is going to stick
to this presidency that is one of those
things that and you know you can always
tell when something is repeated by
people you agree with and disagree with
on social media what when it has like
that kind of reverberation um because so
many people they they think in pictures
you know and and that's what they latch
on to and i think you know in terms of
terror i i hope to god that there's not
a terror attack here but i think we've
grown so complacent and we have given
over so many of our civil liberties
during the pandemic that you know we
could have a massive compromise if
there's a terror attack here and to your
point i don't trust anyone in the
federal government to do any kind of
vetting because they have shown their
failure over and over and over again
though the one greg was talking about
silver linings i think cops will come
out better from this because they have
been so demonized during the pandemic
that now when you see nypd officers with
the counter-terrorism badge on their
uniforms people go okay good someone's
here who's actually going to pay
attention to stuff and they're going to
keep me safe so there you go just one
last note about this my translator for
many years in afghanistan is hiding out
in kabul hoping to get one of those
rides through the taliban roadblocks to
the airport many
international groups are working to get
that to make that happen but it's
something that is extremely concerning
to too many of them hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else